this is joint work with direction mirror
who is on her way I'm told she had some
transportation issues as many of us did
Ramon Carthoris sibron isaacman and
Margaret Martin OC and um okay oh do I
have to do this right to do that let's
see us all right then I do that ah ok
we'll give it one minute and then we'll
give up oh ok this works no there ok
very good very good sorry I didn't
preview the technology before going so
um we're looking at in the context of
human mobility modeling so human
mobility models models of how people
move about in their in their daily lives
have many applications in a broad range
of fields including things like mobile
computing and provisioning for mobile
computing but also in urban planning and
where you where you put roads where you
build bridges and total some things like
this in issues of Epidemiology and
understanding where people connect and
how people connect and also in ecology
and understanding the implications of
the human world on the natural world and
so in particular Ramon casarez my
colleague on this is at 80 where they
have cellular telephone networks and
they have the data and this is a great
source of the the kinds of data that can
be used to tell you where people are
because there are billions of cell
phones in use the the cell phone
providers need the locations of those
phones so that they can provide service
to those phones so they already have
those locations and the phones are
typically with the people who use the
phones and so this data can give you a
very good sense of where people are but
of course there are privacy issues with
using this kind of data so we don't want
to reveal a lot of the information
that's in that that data real
individuals homes or works or locations
at any given time and of course a
stripping obvious I
fires is not good enough and if you need
more on that go back and watch Katrina's
tutorial in the archive so our
contributions in this work are taking a
differentially private approach for
modeling of big data in the context of
realistically modeling how large
populations move within different
metropolitan areas while ensuring that
the privacy of individuals whose data
ensuring that the private the privacy of
the individuals whose data is used we
get mobility accuracy for some
particular metrics within a small number
of miles from the non private approach
and and this is a practical application
of demonstrating privacy in this in this
sort of big data context so what we
build on is some work that I was not
involved in but several of the the
co-authors on this work are which is the
what they call the we're modeling
approach and the idea in that work is to
identify key spatial and temporal
properties of human mobility and to
extract probability distributions that
represent those properties from
empirical data in particular the source
that we'll be using in our version is
these call detail records that talk
about when and where phone calls were
made with cell phones you can also use
other sources of data in the more
general version of the we're modeling
approach and then they show how to
intelligently sample from these
distributions in order create to create
synthetic CDRs call detail records for
synthetic people and there's nothing
special about the output needing to be
called detail records in terms of
understanding how people move but it had
the advantage that there's actually
already a lot of software out there both
at at cell phone providers and elsewhere
that are that are ready to deal with
these call detail records so that's
useful and also there's something nice
about having the output that you create
be in the same format as the input that
it was so that in some sense at this
point we you can just substitute the
data that's been through their modeling
procedure and later through the
differentially private version of it to
go back and use it in whatever way you
might have used for
tional unmodified CDRs so so is the
input to wear already is a modified CDR
and in particular you've got this this
call detail record for every voice
called a text message that a particular
phone is making and the modified CDRs
already you know even though it's not
enough to strip obvious identifiers zits
generally a procedure that is done and
so even within within AT&T and and other
cell phone providers they typically are
going to be very careful with the real
data and and have some kind of procedure
for for stripping out those obvious
identifiers so here already even with
the the non private version of where
this cell phone actual ID were replaced
with a remapped version it's got the
date and time it actually has the start
date and time and the end date and time
of the calls but we're just going to
work for our purposes with the start
date and time of the call and it also
has a starting and ending cell tower
which again we're just going to think
about the starting one so for our
purposes it has a cell phone ID that
says this cell phone was at this place
in time at this place at this time and
and the cell towers are by ID but we can
replace them with with locations using
an auxiliary table so the work on
actually then doing this mobility
characterization from these CDRs takes
these location samples that are these
these modified CDRs they're sparse in
time and course in space and and don't
have meaning associated with them and so
you know in a line of work over the last
several years isaacman and others showed
that you can use this information to put
put more context in it so they showed
that you can see things well like how
far people travel in a given day and
also that just from these locations
where the phone is during the course of
the day or not even where the phone is
but actually where the phone has
activity it makes these calls or texts
you can infer accurately home locations
work locations and other important
locations and and they validated their
results against ground truth both from
actual volunteers who were in the data
that said yes you got mine right or
other sources things like census data
and some others can give you some
estimates of daily range of travel and
one difference in this approach versus
other approaches from getting these
cydia is it's it's very light in terms
of cost in the sense that the data is
already there for other purposes and I
mean in some sense this is why privacy
is a problem when you have big data so
it's it's it's a it's this is this this
work is sort of a good example of
showing the power of what you can get
out of data and then sort of selectively
adding in some privacy as well well
while trying to retain that utility so
so the where approach overall is to
start with the CDRs use their methods
for inferring home and work locations
for each ID and adding those in so what
you end up with is a cell phone ID a
date and time a lat long location and
then appended with the inferred home
location associated with that phone ID
and the inferred work location
associated that ID they in their work
actually can go on with other locations
you know the third most likely place
that you would spend time but in our
work we use justice version where you've
got the two locations and and then they
use these to apply a modeling procedure
to create a model of the users and their
call behavior based on these kinds of
records and then they show how to use
those mod mod those that model to create
synthetic users and calls based on that
model and so so once they've done the
modeling you can then sort of create as
many synthetic data sets as you would
want from that so graphically and I'm
not going to go into a lot of detail of
how this is done and this is for the New
York area here which is one that they
studied extensively as well as LA and
some others first you have once you've
had these inferred home locations you
have a distribution represented by this
heat map of home locations in the
geographic area similarly you have one
for work distributions and then to
select us in to create a synthetic user
you pick a home according to this you
know by sampling for this distribution
they then look at the commute
distributions which are so the whole
area has a grid associated with it
course or grid will sort of be more
aggregate an arrow or grid will be more
refined but you have some grid and so
associated with each cell of the grid
you have a distribution of commutes and
miles meaning distances between inferred
homes and inferred works and so once
you've selected this home yeah I assume
that you're not that's right that's not
in this date I mean obviously the the
providers have that data we both we in
DP where and even in the original where
that data was not made use of and in
summons a lot of the decisions that that
my co-authors and the other people they
worked with in creating where they were
already thinking about privacy and
trying not to do anything sort of
obviously privacy bad and so that was
one choice they made there is not to do
things like say oh you're in the same
place and you have this relationship I
mean obviously there's there's all kinds
of utility you can get from that but
that's not something word that's even
it's not even represented already in the
inputs to the wanting procedure here
yeah it's a little more subtle than that
but but that's a good approximation yeah
and so I see my time it's running quick
so I'll go through a little hazari right
so they have this commute distribution
that's associated with with the grid you
choose from that a specific one sampling
from that distribution and then and then
the way that they're modeling procedure
works you then choose a work
distribution on the the induced
distribution of work locations at that
distance D so in some sense it's keeping
some of the correlation between the
actual homes and actual works or the
inferred actual homes and actual works
but it but it's losing some of the
correlation so it's another step that in
some send in an intuitive way is also
trying to get at this privacy utility
trade-off and then a
you choose a work location there and
that gives you your synthetic user and
then for making calls you again they go
back to the distributions induced by the
data at some granularity and locate the
person in their home or work locations
and calls that they make according to
activity times at each of those
locations cells so some cells are very
active for phone calls and summer are
less in the whole data set and so they
use that and you can repeat that that is
needed for as many days months whatever
as you want to produce us as many
synthetic users as you want and as long
a duration of their calls as you want so
in a graphical format the the way this
looks is you have a bunch of step that
create distributions these are the steps
that actually rely on the the input data
and then you have a bunch of steps that
just use those distributions in a way
that they've found works well to create
synthetic users and their calls and
here's an example of a typical weekday
in the New York area of the real CDRs
over here and the way or synthetic CDRs
over here just showing where people are
making calls at given times and you know
obviously this is just a visualization
not a not a sort of a metric but what I
want you to see here is they look not
too different and so you you know they
did lots of work in their validation on
sort of showing in some sense that they
aren't too different but moving on to
the privacy apart which is here you know
obviously there are privacy concerns
when detailed call data is used you know
even though we don't have the the call
graph of who's calling who we have these
inferred homes and works which we said
we're good because they're very accurate
we have usage patterns and locations and
as we know it's not enough to simply d
anonymize by stripping the obvious
identifiers zand for all the reasons
that that Katrina addressed in her
tutorial differential privacy we think
is a very good privacy goal and one that
we're going to use here and I'm just
going to skip through since we've
already heard that background on reasons
you might care about differential
privacy on the actual definition and
some consequences of it but i will say
for us what makes neighbor so it's the
same the same idea if we want to
databases to be neighboring if they
differ
one individual and so in particular our
rose when I was drawing them were the
call detail records but our neighbors is
going to be looking at the whole block
of Rose associated what are they any
particular phone ID so that it really is
about one individual and not just one
individual call and so then really what
we've done in this work is is use all
the tools and existing results out there
about good ways to achieve differential
privacy in the specific context of this
application so for example you can
easily take the distribution of homes
and make the construction of that
differentially private by using mobile
plus mechanism because the sensitivity
is not very big and so so that's that's
easily done by the Laplace distribution
and if you look at it for varying values
of epsilon in that New York City data
said that they have in fact you have to
get to really very tiny epsilons before
you could even see the difference from
the real data to to the to the the
differentially private constructed data
in this representation is a cumulative
distribution function of that home
distribution so basically what we did is
go through all the distributions and and
look at what we found as a good way to
add in differential privacy that has
seen seems to work well with it with a
small enough epsilon and good enough
accuracy so as I said these are the only
places where we actually have to go back
to the data and so what we do for DP
where is we insert in our case it's
almost every step really is an adding
noise type of step oh but more
accurately this would be an algorithm
for a mechanism for putting in
differential privacy to to get to these
distributions that were created in a
differentially private matter everything
else can be done exactly as it was
before and in particular just like with
where we could stop here and release
these distributions as a model and
anyone else could use them either in
this exact way or any other way that
they want to so the overall approach
then is we're going to produce
individual distributions these sort of
empirical cumulative distribution
functions like the one that I showed you
for home in differentially private
manner and
if I show you how to do each one of them
then by composition theorems the overall
way of constructing the results whether
as you stop in the model or go on and
continue to use it you get DP whereas an
epsilon differentially private algorithm
for constructing these models and
synthetic users where the epsilon
overall is the sum of the epsilon that
I'm going to use for each of the
distributions so I'm not going to have
time to to tell you how each
distribution is done and I'm not sure
how instructive it would be anyway but
the overall idea is what we were doing
this paper was was really looking at
ways of using these known methods in a
combination that pursued through dulcis
here and I should say so I described all
those distributions in some case that
they're actually families it's
distributions because we have one for
every grid cell or one for every hour
but but the same idea applies and then
we had to make some sort of practical
choices based on the intended
application to metropolitan scale so
things like well you'll see when an
example comes up so for both home and
work there's low global sensitivity and
we were able to just use the laplace
method plus some post processing
techniques of hay and McClellan others
to turn them back into a proper
cumulative distribution function because
we wanted to produce something that that
if you released those distributions
could still be used exactly as the where
distributions could so we want to make
sure they were distributions the others
were a little bit more complicated so
for commute distance as I said that you
there we assume an underlying grid on
the space which can be as fine or coarse
as you like each grid cell is going to
have a distribution for the homework
commute distances for that cell and so
the way we compute them is is similar to
the way that we're already computes them
except that we need to add in some
privacy and we wanted to avoid having
empty cells because that would create
some problems for the privacy and so we
just add it in and this is where you
know we said you know based on on the
the scenarios we were imagining these
are these are both small commutes and
shouldn't change the overall effect too
much but this is this is somewhere where
certainly we're making
judgment that might or might not apply
in all cases and then after doing that
we used half of a private of the privacy
budget associated with the commute
distance to determine histogram bins to
use and we did that using an efficient
version of the exponential mechanism
that was mentioned before as was done in
some other work and an efficient in
particular in terms of known methods for
sampling were available here and then we
use the other half of the remaining
budget to compute noisy counts on the
the bins themselves using the plus
mechanism to get the resulting
distributions so that's just an example
of sort of you know mixing and matching
from from different existing techniques
and similarly in the others calls per
day we we used some some known
techniques and got some results there as
well as in call time and out early
location and then you know really what
we were interested in looking and seeing
you know it doesn't seem to be working
so we came back to this case study of
New York which is why that's the one
that I showed so the raw data the real
date of the original data a billion over
a billion phones sorry over a billion
records from about 260,000 phones in a
data collection period of 91 days and
2011 synthetic data sets that we looked
at we looked at using both where and DP
where for varying values of total
epsilon all added together for ten
thousand phones and six million call
detail records and so we compared the
resulting synthetic sets both to each
other for the different values of
epsilon and to the original CD RS and so
here's now a video of the real CDRs on
the left and the DP where synthetic CDRs
with epsilon equals 0 point 23 on the
right here and you know i think what i
want you to see here on this one is it's
still not too different but it is more
different than it was when it was the
real CDRs and where and i think they're
not quite aligned in time I we had some
trouble with that so if you you know you
can see this kind of diffuses a little
earlier and then now
I I have to I can't tell you whether
that's just an artifact of the timing or
whether it's actually in the real
results right now and if you look at the
distributions you can you can again see
that the individual ones are very kind
aren't that difference and there's
there's more details in the paper and
then we also want to look really sort of
if your end goal is how you're going to
use the things we want to look at how is
it really behaving overall so we have
some ways of doing that looking at the
popular density distribution which is
really what that that movie was showing
and captures a great behavior and then
also looking at some of the the
distances how far to individuals move
and so very quickly since I see my time
is up what we had a sort of an upper
bound if you use where without your CDRs
at all from all public sources of data
using the best public sources of data
that they could find to do that you get
and so here a distance we want lower is
is closer to real and and higher is bad
so if you use all public data with where
you can get here so if adding privacy
put you above that there'd be no point
to do that you might as well just go
back to the public data where by itself
all with the CD ours is this blue one
and then for varying values of overall
epsilon we get this and this bike is
really here because in these smaller
hours of the day there's not very many
calls so the variance is higher and and
then we also looked at this daily range
which the question you're asking is how
far do people travel and so these are
the mean and standard deviation for
those or both for the real CDRs for
where and for DP where again with that
epsilon equal to 0 point 23 overall so
overall so we we have these synthetic
CDRs produced by DP where which mimic to
some degree the real movement seen in
the real CDRs while preserving privacy
in the sense of differential privacy and
you know we think this is a good case
study for differential privacy and for
looking at how it really acts ATT is
actually currently using it internally
for testing purposes so I think at this
point I think all they really care about
is that it the data is in the right
format and that they can handle a lot of
it coming through
we passed that but we're hopeful that
that it'll be better than that and
actually I can't know too much about
that I mean 18 ideas TNT is very careful
about its actual data and how it uses it
and what it tells people about it all
these things so so I don't know if I'll
be able to report more when it's
actually being used but I can tell you
that it is too early for that now and I
think some open questions that this
brings up you know is this really good
enough for real use clearly it will
depend on the application but we're
hopeful that there are some applications
that it would be good for all so we kind
of did an ad hoc division of the overall
epsilon both into those six parts for
the six distribution and then within
them some of them had part of the
privacy budget used in one way in part
in another so you know in addition to
the question that's not really well
addressed as a whole you know is it bias
as a community as a whole yet of what is
your epsilon to choose is even then more
subtly how you do how do you best divide
up your epsilon even once you have one
this seems also to be very application
dependent and then we hope to be able to
make those models available in the
future the raw data will not be
available I believe I have no power over
the raw data I've no power over the
synthetic data in fact but we hope the
synthetic data might be available ah i
would have to consult with sibron and
direction to give you an exact number it
was long enough that making changes to
the algorithm that the last minute ran
into trouble with paper deadlines but
not so long enough that we couldn't make
it so I want to say it was a you know it
was at least an overnight it would
depend on me so there was the once you
have the distributions generating the
synthetic data is quite easy but
creating the distributions from the raw
data takes longer now there's a sampling
step that I that I didn't mention but we
actually sampled only you know I think
something like five percent or ten
percent of the of the billion calls in
the first place
so the course our sample or sample that
you do the the less data you're working
with and the faster overall that would
be but but direction will be here later
and she can give you a better answer to
that question no no i mean so it's a
yeah maybe I mean so there's certainly
there's an interplay between because I
told you about the grid for the commute
distance but there's even gridding for
how finely grained I mean the even that
homes and works were not identified at
the location of a building but they were
maybe zip codes I mean they were they
were more you know they were lat long
quadrants but but certainly there's some
interplay there and that that's
something else to look at for sure